the political crisis engulfing the
british prime minister keeps on growing
boris johnson is under pressure to
resign but will he and what are the
implications of unsitting a prime
minister in the uk and what could it all
mean for british politics this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
daddy nabogada britain's prime minister
boris johnson has been defying calls to
quit over a lockdown violation scandal
johnson attended parties in his downing
street residents while the rest of the
country was being told to isolate or pay
hefty fines if they broke coveted rules
but he said he won't step down over the
so-called party gate scandal
johnson faces the prospect of a
no-confidence vote among mps in the
coming days one mp from johnson's
conservative party has defected to the
opposition and others are reported to
have already submitted letters of no
confidence
neve barker sent this report from london
in a highly charged atmosphere prime
minister's questions began with another
major body blow for boris johnson news
one of his mps christian wakeford had
defected to the opposition party
this following morning newspaper reports
of a widening plot to aust johnson by
members of his own party
jokes that the prime minister's expense
followed i see the very noise i'm sure
the chief whip is told to bring their
own boos
salvo after salvo
nobody told the prime minister he was
breaking his own rules
absolutely pathetic
if he had any shred of compassion for
all those out there who suffered through
this he'd go
mps clamoring for explanations from
johnson about the increasing catalogue
of rule-breaking parties that took place
under his watch when the country was
deep in lockdown
but the prime minister seemed energized
fighting tooth and nail for his party
and his job
when the history of this pandemic comes
to be written and the history of the
labour party comes to be written and
believe me they are history and will
remain history mr speaker it will show
it will show it will show that we
delivered while they dithered and we
we vaccinated while they vacillated mr
speaker i am intensely proud of what
this government has done
and call after call for johnson to
resign was met with the same message
to reserve judgment and wait for the
results of the inquiry into a growing
list of rule breaking mr speaker when a
prime minister is spending his time
trying to convince the great british
public that he's actually stupid rather
than dishonest isn't it time that he
goes now
but his voices from his own party that
could do the most damage to his
political future
mp david davis wants the teresa may
government's chief brexit negotiator
delivering this surgical strike like
many on these benches i spent weeks and
months defending the prime minister
against often angry constituents but i
expect my leaders
to shoulder the responsibility
for the actions they take
yesterday he did the opposite of that
so i'll remind him of a quotation
altogether too familiar to him of leo
amory to neville chamberlain you have
sat there too long for all the good you
have done in the name of god go
despite the full force of bran boris
back on show and despite the promise
that plan b coveted restrictions will be
slashed from next week this was a
bruising day in parliament for the prime
minister seemingly impossible for him to
escape all the growing anger within his
conservative party and with the results
of a potentially damaging inquiry just
around the corner boris johnson's days
in office could soon be numbered
neve barker al jazeera westminster
so an official inquiry is investigating
several cases in which johnson and his
downing street staff are accused of
violating lockdown rules in may of 2020
a leaked photo shows boris johnson and
his wife along with 20 of his staff in
the downing street garden eating cheese
and drinking wine
again that same month a leaked email
reveals staff were invited to the same
garden for drinks 40 people are believed
to have attended
in november of that year the british
media reports that 50 people along with
the prime minister had drinks to mark
the departure of one of his aides a
month after another leaked photo shows
staff sharing drinks and food at the
conservative party headquarters and
again that month johnson was
photographed sitting between two staff
members at a christmas zoom quiz
three days later another party was held
in downing street according to british
media and then last year two parties are
reported to have taken place in april
the night before the funeral for prince
philip that was while the country was in
a period of official mourning while
downing street has apologized to the
queen
let's discuss all of this with our
guests joining us from london is john
pete who is the brexit and political
editor of the economist in falkirk
julian mckay is a member of the scottish
parliament and member of scottish green
party also in london mustafa rahman
who's the managing director for europe
at eurasia group welcome to the program
thanks so much for joining us on inside
story jillian mckay if i may start with
you
the prime minister has said that he's
taken responsibility for his handling of
the downing street parties and insists
that everyone should wait for the
findings of that official inquiry being
conducted by sue gray before reaching
any sort of judgment but you are calling
for the prime minister to go are you
saying that he needs to go now and if so
tell us why
the prime minister should have gone at
the start of this scandal the prime
minister and those in his inner circle
clearly think that they're above the
rules as you've laid out they've
breached the rules several times
repeatedly and deliberately they've
tried to cover it up and some have even
been caught laughing about it and it's
no laughing matter for those of us
who've lost a loved one during the
pandemic
boris johnson is completely unfit to be
prime minister and it is beyond time for
him to go but why don't we not wait why
not just wait for the report that that's
due out that we understand next week
i think he is now beyond reproach to be
perfectly honest his excuses have
changed consistently he's deaf almost
certainly misled parliament we've got
calls from his own back benches to
resign and today we've heard from a
senior mp
of allegations of blackmail against mps
who
would
undermine johnson so i think
we don't really need to wait for
something they've already admitted to
the prime minister himself has admitted
that he was at that party but didn't
know that it was a party um he would
have known that that was the numbers of
people alone was breaking the rules so
he really is trying to
trying to get out of this by playing
stupid rather than playing deliberate
and ignorant
all right john what's your take on this
i mean some mps are saying that they are
still waiting for this report is that
going to be the next key moment here
yes it is going to be the next key
moment i mean i think there was a point
on tuesday of this week when it looked
as if enough conservative mps would say
we've had it um we're fed up with
johnson and we're worried that we're
going to lose the next election and lose
many of our seats and they then looked
as if they were on the verge of calling
for a confidence date but i think after
yesterday the mood has changed a little
bit towards saying let's wait for this
report um see how bad this report is and
in particular see if this report says
that boris johnson concludes that boris
johnson misled parliament
if that happens i think there will be a
confidence vote so the next big point is
indeed the publication of the report but
even if he gets through that i think the
mood in the party is that they're very
worried that boris johnson had lost the
confidence of voters and is taking the
conservative party into a position where
they may lose the next election john
though the the prime minister's
admission and apology in the commons
did it by him some time though i mean do
you think that he'll he'll survive the
next few days at least without a no
confidence vote
he's going to survive into next week but
i think next week could be a difficult
time for him again when the report comes
out
i think his performance yesterday did
buy him a bit of time and bizarrely the
the defection of a conservative mp and
and his decision to join labor also
helped him because it led tory rebels to
worry that if they take this too far
they may be opening the door to
a labor administration but his denials
and his apologies have not really cut
through to the ordinary voters they
think he's just lying that they don't
believe his apologies they think the
line that he thought it was a work event
not a party is incredible um and i think
that they feel that they've lost
confidence in their their prime minister
all right
can you weigh in on all of this and tell
us i mean do you think that he'll be
able to survive the findings after the
report comes out
i'd agree very much with john i think uh
the moon in westminster is
violently swinging back and forth and i
i do think tuesday
uh the result of opinion polls in the
red wall that suggested johnson has lost
some of his
sparkle
in those crucial seats in the north and
the midlands lots of reports in
westminster
about red wall mps caucusing to send
those letters into segregate brady
chairman of the 1922 committee to
trigger that vote of confidence and then
of course the defection yesterday
of christian the wakeford to the labor
side i think the combination of those
three things really um i think meant
johnson was in trouble yesterday and i
agree with john that actually his
performance and the defection the
combination of those two things have
brought him
a little bit of time but i think next
week is now the point of maximum danger
for the prime minister
and the sue grey report we know
is not going to make a determination on
johnson it will present the facts and
then it will leave it to others to make
a judgment about whether
um johnson has lied and subsequently and
ultimately misled parliament and i think
that is going to be a perilous moment
for the prime minister
assuming
you do get 54 letters then into sigrin
brady it's still a big jump to then get
181 mps which is what you would need to
win a vote of confidence okay so do you
think that the 54
do you think that the 54 letters will
actually
um be reached i mean for what we now
know so far is that so far 11
conservative mps have publicly at least
declared no confidence uh in the prime
minister so
do you think that momentum is going to
keep on growing
i think a lot will hang on the wording
and johnston's reaction to the sugree
report only sigraine brady knows how
many letters have been received there's
of course
mps that are on the record but many may
have gone in that we don't know about i
think
brady has probably given indications to
number 10 about how serious the
situation is i suspect that is why
downing street has signaled that they
would fight
a confidence vote and again i think
that's why
getting to the 181 tory mps is going to
be quite a challenge assuming johnson
does get through
the next week and this will be my final
point then of course
there's going to be a big challenge in
the aftermath of the may authority local
elections where i suspect the tories
will do very badly and at that point of
course inflation will be peaking and the
concerns around cost of living will be
very ever present for mps in parliament
um jillian
the mood in the in the conservative
party and i think you alluded to this as
well is that it's being described as
sort of very tumultuous but um do you
think the mps in the conservative party
want a crisis right now on their hands
such as this
i think they've been given a crisis
whether they want one
or not and it's very much
up to those mps at westminster
to
to advocate for the the views of those
um
constituents like david davis alluded to
who are furious
at the level the level of flippance from
the prime minister i think some of
um some of what i've heard from
constituents about his performances at
um prime minister's questions where he's
trying to deflect they're bringing out
policies to try and um deflect
some of the heat from the prime minister
is only adding to that
that co that lack of confidence from
from the public i think
some of the tories now really have to
decide whether they want to continue
under this morally bankrupt government
that they have or whether they're going
to stand with their constituents and as
as the other um or other panelists have
said that could affect them very very
badly at the local elections both in
england and in scotland in may as well
john you know those who support the
prime minister say that well this is a
man who led the uk through
a crisis of course like the pandemic and
national crisis and maybe he should be
given some credit i mean what do you
think of that argument
well he does have a sort of hardcore
supporters um in in obviously in the
conservative party itself um and indeed
many of the conservative mps who won and
seats in the 2019 election recognized
that they did say because because of
boris johnson his charisma his promise
to get brexit done
and so on and the sort of switch from
theresa may who who had been in effect
pushed out by by the party in in 2019
but i think the the issue that tory mp
are grappling with is that it's not
enough to have support inside the
conservative party he needs to have
support of voters in the end um and the
voters seem to have become disillusioned
particularly over these parties but to
some extent over the handing of covid
over his chaotic image over the
arguments he's been having with some of
his advisers notably dominic cummings it
that downing street looks rather chaotic
and disorganized and i think voters
don't like that they think you know
government should be should be better
ordered and and that's really the
underlying issue here what are the
latest schools i'm telling you john
about the public's mood and what they
want to see happen
they're now saying that um boris
johnson's boris johnson's popularity
rating is below that of theresa may and
theresa may was was very unpopular
towards the end of her time in office
because she was failing to deliver to
deliver brexit so he is he was never a
very popular prime minister that's one
of the things to note about him he was
never as popular as people like tony
blair um or even in his day john major
but he had enough of a rating to to win
a large majority in the last election
and now i think the negatives against
him which were always higher than many
people realized have climbed to to a
level where tory mps conservative mps
worry that they could lose the next
election and as long as that continues
it is a big thing to push out a prime
minister it hasn't happened very often
it happened most famously with margaret
thatcher but given that they worry about
what might happen it is something that
could happen at any time even if he
survives the next week next few weeks
and months
muslim i mean john was just mentioning
theresa may she did go through this in
2018 of course and mp submitted enough
letters to trigger a confidence vote in
her but then when the vote came she
survived it
uh mr johnson himself
has survived sort of intense storms
before if i can put it that way can you
see that happening to him
i mean i think it's probably
too late for johnson i think the
political context the economic context
is very challenging indeed omicron in
the government's eyes uh uh maybe
around you know we may be moving
on from omicron and turning that corner
but around the next corner is a massive
cost of living crisis inflation is set
to reach i believe seven percent in the
uk this year
so i think the economic challenges the
government will face in the latter part
of the year are going to be a very very
big
problem for the government that will i
think weigh down on johnson
i don't think after the local authority
elections he will be able to recover so
our officer our viewer at this point is
we're likely to face a leadership
contest in the summer
i think probably the two front runners
in that regard will be uh chancellor
richie sooner and foreign secretary liz
truss i i suspect neither if it does go
to a leadership contest will want to
concede which means tory members will
need to have a say
and and at least from where things sit
at the moment i believe uh chancellor
sunak is most likely
uh to succeed johnson as prime minister
in the second half of the year probably
uh to be announced at the torii
conference in the in the latter part of
the year okay uh julian would you like
to weigh in on on this issue of uh rishi
sunak and and liz trust that mustafa was
just talking about
i think it will come as as no surprise
that uh i completely lack a favorite
tory to take over from from the prime
minister i think part of the problem for
me is the fact that they are continuing
they are some of the people that are
defending the prime minister at the
moment so if we're looking at um the
prime minister is
being completely unfit what does that
say for the rest of the cabinet who are
currently defending him and may have
known about these these parties as well
it's something that the cabinet widely
won't won't answer if they were aware of
what these
what was happening so there's a much
wider problem at the heart of the uk
government which really scotland has to
get out from under as as quickly as is
possible because we're seeing
more and more abhorrent policies coming
forward the one that was announced over
the weekend um about using force against
refugees in the channel is just
horrendous and it's something that as a
country we should not be standing for
uh john um
would you like to respond to what julian
was saying
well i mean i think you know enemies of
the tory party are clearly quite growing
and many people worry about the
direction that this government is taking
but back to the question of who
who might succeed uh boris johnson i
think i would agree with machtava that
um that rishi sunak is the favorite the
only thing i would add is that past
experience suggests that favorites often
don't win in the end um and and funnily
enough the front runner is often sort of
picked out as somebody who everybody
else has a go at and then somebody else
can emerge so i i wouldn't like to be
absolutely you know certain on
predicting who might take over from
johnson at the end of this year right
okay and what about the opposition party
john because the obviously i mean the
opposition is lapping this up kier
starmer saying boris johnson should be
kicked out in the national interest how
is this reflecting on them
well i mean kirsten was having a having
a good run it's taken him time to sort
of get get known by the public um you
know he arrived just as kobe had hit the
uk and and so people didn't see much of
him but now they've seen a lot more of
him they've seen a lot more of him in
parliament and i think he has the heir
of somebody who's more serious and
perhaps more trustworthy than boris
johnson and that's clearly helping him
and and his party um he still has a
little way to go um before before he
wins an election but i think at the
moment he is in he's in he's in pretty
good a pretty good position and oddly
enough i think in many ways although of
course he calls for boris johnson to go
as leaders of the opposition always will
do um he's going to be in a better
position if boris johnson stays then if
if johnson goes and somebody like rishi
sunak takes over um he's more likely to
win against johnson than anybody else
jillian the the prime minister's former
top a dominic cummings has been sort of
i guess instrumental in all of this
saying that he himself had warned boris
johnson about uh number 10 holding a
drinks party in the garden during
lockdown but he also said that the prime
minister uh just kind of waved aside
the concerns about the gatherings
could this be seen as some sort of
vendetta uh by comings
for some i'm sure it it could be but um
i think dominic cummings has found has
maybe
found a sense of a sense of truth and
has decided to
um unearth a lot of the the problems at
the heart of government
no matter what these things shouldn't
have happened whether revealed by
dominic cummings whether they're
revealed by other members of um downing
street staff or whether they're unveiled
by the
by the press the these things should not
be happening they are
flying in the face of everything that
they asked the public to do and the
public have done brilliantly without the
public adhering to these restrictions we
could have seen a much worse position
and for me that's one of the the big
concerns going forward as we progress
through the rest and hopefully the end
of this
pandemic is that
if our leaders haven't stuck to the the
rules that were set down what hope do we
have of the public adhering to any more
rules that we might have to bring in if
we get a worse um
variant sometime in the future
also on cummings he went on to say that
the prime minister had actually lied to
parliament about the parties so
effectively does this mean
the accusation is that the prime
minister has breached the ministerial
code
yes i think cummings clearly
is out to unseat johnson
um i think you know that's obviously a
very big part of his
his mission he's a a big champion and
supporter of rishi soon apps by suspect
in attempting to unseat johnson you will
also be attempting to get an ally into
number 10 to advance
the post-brexit agenda especially around
leveling up which
i think many in whitehall and west
minister believe that sunak would have a
better better shot at implementing than
than johnson has or indeed will over the
remainder of this term if he does indeed
survive so i think
i think cummings will continue to pile
on the pressure i think that does create
risk of course because
um having served johnson for so many
years he obviously has a stash of emails
and evidence and things that he can
continue throwing at the pm
to create problems and i think that's
going to be the issue for johnson
every second we think he has stabilized
something else pops along
most notably through dominic cummings's
blog and i suspect that will continue to
be the case until um johnson is still
wounded the party decides to remove him
all right we will have to see what
happens in the next few days but for the
time being thank you so much uh for
speaking to us uh john pete julian mckay
and mustafa rahman thanks for joining us
thank you for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website aljazeera.com for further
discussion you can go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj insight story join the conversation
on twitter our handle is aj inside story
from myself and the whole team here in
doha thanks for watching bye for now
[Music]
[Music]
you